lorsque vous aurez choisi votre arbre je
vous invite à s'approcher de lui et a
soufflé à souffler votre prénom
touché un arbre pour se reconnecter à la
nature à soi-même se débarrasser de ses
soucis isabelle partage son amour pour
la nature en ce week-end réservé aux
amoureux
elle propose une séance de civaux
thérapie à bonnel pour être bien pour
gérer son stress
on peut aller dans la nature et profiter
notamment des arbres avec les terpènes
et puis ton side et tous les bienfaits
qu'ils ont naturellement et qui nous
font du bien
une animation précédé d'un repas le
vendredi soir à l'hôtel le barney ouvert
en juin 2018
au menu volaille sauce au vin jaune à
partager nous avons tout de même créé un
menu pour cette fête là et nous allons
plus jouer sur un côté drôle je dirais
de la fête en question un côté amusant
plus que de l'apprendre de manière très
sérieuse comme elle peut l'être très
commercial à maurepas c'est une soirée
sans valentin qui est proposée petit
love room avec speed dating au programme
et un concert mené par un dj une soirée
réservée à tous ces pas réservé aux
amoureux on aura un système de bracelet
on donnera des brasses les roses pour
les gens qui sont célibataires et qui
veulent faire des rencontres et pour
celles qui veulent être tranquilles on
donnera d'autres bras semaine tête à
tête au coeur de la nature ou encore
autour d'un verre l'amour se vivra ce
week-end avec et sans modération